[Music]
i'm trying to time it as the tide is
going out
but eventually it's going to come back
once it does then the clock is ticking
my name is andres amador i'm best known
for doing
large scale artworks on the beach
most artists strive to make something
that might end up in a museum one day
something permanent but not amadore
his work only lasts a few hours
so the design will disappear like
inevitably
no questions the tide is going to return
and it's going to wash it away
and no matter how much i might want to
hold on to whatever i created
built into this artwork is a letting go
of the creation
lots of people find it calming to
scratch ideas in the sand
but amador takes this idea to the next
level
over the past 15 years he's etched close
to
1 000 awe-inspiring designs onto beaches
around the world
[Music]
during low tide i have a wet canvas
that's as big as the beach will
offer me and i'll rake on that which
turns over the sand that is a bit dry on
the top but it's still wet below
and so that contrast those are the lines
those are my brush strokes
he draws a lot of inspiration from a
mathematical principle
known as fractals which are essentially
patterns that repeat themselves
over and over no matter the scale
fractals are the mathematical way to
connect what's happening in nature
the way that i'm connecting to natural
pattern
is through recognizing that there is a
process that's occurring when you talk
about
the fractal nature itself similar so
what's happening at the small level is
also happening at the large level
generally speaking and now i might be
vastly simplifying
it but really that's only because that's
the way that i'm able to connect to this
i need to keep things relatively simple
so that i can keep it together for
myself
once he comes up with a design the trick
is figuring out how to translate that
idea
onto a canvas that's constantly changing
amador has a degree in environmental
science and worked for years as a
computer technician
but he always had artistic ambitions in
2004 he was on vacation in hawaii
drawing circles in the sand when he had
an epiphany
it dawned on me that i could create
designs at an enormous level by
using geometry the beach was the perfect
place
and as soon as i realized that it was
off and running
[Music]
the first step in his process is
choosing which style to work with
the two major categories in my artwork i
would call the geometric
and the organic but that could also be
called like the classical physics and
the newtonian
where there's right angles and straight
lines and prescribed
dimensions versus chaos and
randomness if he's going the geometric
route he'll start by designing the
pattern in an
app called concepts when i'm doing the
geometric work
there is built into the design a natural
ending point
so maybe the largest has been maybe 200
feet across
and the more organic artwork can go on
for hundreds and hundreds of feet
or tens of thousands of square feet
filling up a whole
beach area because really there's no
boundary to it so i can just keep going
the geometric is an exercise in
intellectual ability
with the organic it's emerging in the
moment
there's a spontaneity that is really
it's delightful
i resonate much more with that that said
over the years
as i've discovered more ways to engage
the spectrum
of the structured and the organic
now my work weaves back and forth
one of the problems with doing the
geometric art is that because it's so
perfect
it looks just like a stamp people would
accuse me online that i was
photoshopping it in there
one way to avoid that critique is to
integrate the designs
into the environment these days i'm
looking for one
that offers features on the beach that i
can engage
so just having a design on a big open
expanse of beach
there's not that feeling of place that
this artwork is existing within a
location
so i desire to have interesting features
on the beach to rock out crops
or a spur of the mountain that's going
down into the water
or the cliff side that i can just blend
into so the design gets disrupted by
the landscape in some way or it has to
move around the landscape in some way
that the artwork
and the landscape are involved in a
dialogue
so these are my main tools extendable
rake
thinner rakes and these are also
extendable
these are for fine lines and also for a
bit of marking
and then this pole here i'll be using
today so that i can
create guides for myself
so this is the area that i want to do
the work in i really want
to include these rocks so my first step
is to
determine how long this thing is going
to be for expediency i'll be using
some rope and a tape measure so that i
can quickly mark out my points
from the center point i'm going to
create an outer perimeter there really
isn't a circle in this design but
i'm creating a hexagon six lines coming
out of the center but really three
straight lines
that divide the circle into six parts
six pie shakes
so right now we're looking at one of the
pie slices of the six
slices that i have created from those
pie shapes i'll start to connect
some of the outer points to create what
will eventually become the grid
then i'll go to a different tool so it's
a pole with two nails in it
which will create a perfectly separated
pathway
i'll use that to start blocking out
major areas
at that point the canvas is going to be
just be full of criss-crossing lines
everywhere and the challenge at that
point is going to be
keeping it straight where i am and then
i will take my expanding rake to make
thick lines
that's the place where it's very easy to
get lost
it is totally like being in
a maze once i make a mark in the sand
that mark pretty much can't go away
almost invariably on every piece i do i
make
some mark that's wrong so there's an
error in
every one of my designs
over the past decade he turned his hobby
into a profession
he sells prints from photos he takes
with his drone
he does commissions and he also leads
workshops with
other aspiring beach artists
i would say there's two main challenges
there's a time constraint
so i'm very aware of the tide
when it's hit its maximum low and it's
coming back
or if it's already coming back like the
time pressure
of if i don't finish this soon
then a major chunk of this could get
washed away
i have had many times where i'm just
nearing the finish and a wave comes and
just eats out huge chunks of it and then
the next
challenge is to really to keep my step
straight
because it's easy to get lost in the
process and to be looking at my
instructions
scratching my head as to what does that
mean right here on the ground
that i'm supposed to be doing i can see
on the paper what it means but
what does that mean right here i've been
in a situation so many times
because i had a very complex design and
while i was designing it seemed
very obvious what would happen next and
where that would be but on the ground
the distance is so big that it's easy to
lose track of
what's happening so keeping it together
that really is the biggest
challenge ultimately because if you
can't keep it together and you're
spending your time trying to figure it
out then you're using up time
so what i try to design towards is where
i minimize the places where i need to be
making decisions
while i'm working and that each step is
very clear and i'm minimizing how much i
need to think about it
as i'm working even when i complete a
piece and it's perfect
it's going to go away there's nothing i
can do about it but the process to get
there
is as important or perhaps more
important and so this art has connected
me to the act
as it's happening and the value of
focusing on that experience versus
the result